я вважаю, що молдова повинна відновити
стратегічного партнерства з російською
федерації і я сказав сьогодні європейським
керівником та різних структур що якщо
ситуація не зміниться на наступних
парламентських виборах буде інше
парламентська більшість що швидше
всього вийде з ініціативою анулювання
угода без зникла і в цьому випадку
президент молдови, тобто я я не зможу
від нього нічого протиставити
але я неодноразово про це говорив і
публічно відома моя позиція
я вважаю що молдова більше виграє від
інтеграції в єврозас
тому що з точки зору економіки з
точки зору створення робочих місць без
традиційних ринків без ринку в Росії
recovery в рази asmolova не вижити
якщо формат переговорів це формат 5+2
а я вважаю що протягом наступних
півтора два два з половиною роки у нас
відкривається вікно можливостей для
вирішення придністровської його конфлікту
протестантських проблем знайти я думаю що
всім і заходу та сходу потрібну
історії успіху я думаю що це потрібно і
європейського союзу та Росії та з'єднаним
штатам щоб показати що де там можна
домовитися напевно буде важче
домовлятися по Україні
напевно, але по молдові по придністров'ю
для того, щоб реінтегрувати країну я
думаю що домовитись можна